j'ai un petit tour deux cas on va
pouvoir faire participer tout le public
regardez ce que j'ai essayé on a mis une
caméra juste au-dessus hommes j'ai
besoin d'une personne une personne qui
veut participer
monsieur monsieur bonjour venez venez
venez chez moi à l'état d'appliquer la
tournée doux en tissant de nos écrans
très bien mais les faits qu'à regarder
regardez bien ici j'ai qui font un jeu
de cartes cartes avec les cartes toutes
différentes
on est bien d'accord cartes différentes
rien tout le monde entre vous avez passé
votre doigt à l'intérieur attention
n'importe où quand vous le souhaitez de
près
sortie n'ont été trouvés de ses
attentions alors allez hop bien s'amuser
ici regardez la carte montrer la caméra
à la caméra juste derrière vous montrez
là au chroniqueur aux téléspectateurs de
la magie selon gainey en direct sur ces
8 on le rappelle alors c'est le but est
d'abord merci adria on leur pose ici
vous pouvez gagner votre place je n'ai
absolument pas couché le jeu et pourtant
si je prend la première carte qui est ma
garde c'est la dame de pique à ma carte
cela pose ici
sauf que ma carte pas cela et que le roi
de carreau car sélectionnés par adrien
est dû cela
docteur des lourds nord je la place à
l'intérieur au milieu
regardez se claque des doigts air et la
carte pour remonte sur le buzz à présent
regarder bien regarder un ski cela se
passait se claque des doigts on rappelle
que tout les cas totalement différente
je vais faire un paquet 2 3 4 5 à 5
voilà c'est mieux comme ça toi michel
vous me sélectionner les paquets 1 2 3 4
ou 5 4 4 c'est tout ou le 2 litres sur
le 4e j'ai récupéré la carte du
spectateur adrien il s'agissait du roi
de pique le roi de pique le roi carreaux
que l'on place après que l'on place dans
le paquet mais très bien une fois les
vols à la bon ça devrait le faire
ça va le faire dans une pipe en bois ces
cinq là que jean michel vous me
sélectionner le paquet un deux trois
quatre ou cinq banques à un seul louis
que deux rues de celui ci allait dans le
droit de croire le 3
paris demandé à l'ue s'était tue plein
de trois noms pour aller regarder banon
et ça tu allais pas fait
il a dit colin salanon il fallait pas
prendre celui-là à bâle autres bah si tu
veux aller le 5 ou le tissu
je sais plus mais t'as qu'à le chef
choisit d'aller choisir tout ne pas
qu'elle était à l'aise il choisit six
mois un paquet le sac le st-julien très
noir non non non le 3 et 4 hommes
pensent qu'à tomber sur le cas de pic
bon car le carreau mais point s arrête
pas de regarder ya celui une seule carte
dessus vous avez sélectionné on a changé
à plusieurs reprises si c'est le roi de
carreau
je veux que le public se lève
entièrement si c'est la dame de trèfle
on est dans la merde oui attention 3 2 à
ouais
[Applaudissements]
we look at me what you see les quinze
jours oui vous me croyez pas non vous
applaudissent y est eh ben on me l'a
super regarder si peur si ça vous savez
pourquoi est-ce que le bouille on coupe
de cette manière gares des tags mendois
forme je tombais sur une seule
[Applaudissements]
j'ai oublié en fait une double effet il
nous bleu sud mal à venise à thé royal
est ce que vous avez là les bonnes
cartes là non ça c'est alors c'est quoi
annoncer une pochette sa façade ya pas
de carte à l'intérieur non à la fois à
l'intérieur il ya une seule carte
ok prévu depuis le départ malgré tous
les changements secours des pourtant
c'est le roi de carreau et 3,2 à houat
garros
[Applaudissements]
il y a
non
là
allegrini c'est là ça fait
màj elle voilà